hey youtubers is Charlie so I'm gonna
explain what's going on with brexit and
Game of Thrones
don't worry brexit is a human dumpster
fire but it is not gonna burn Game of
Thrones to the ground so if you guys
woke up this morning and you have
absolutely no idea what's going on in
the UK brexit is essentially the UK
voting in a referendum to collectively
leave the European Union and there's a
lot of good things a lot of bad things
this isn't really a political channel or
an economics channel so I'm not gonna
completely explain what's going on with
brexit itself and the reasons you can't
vote it to leave but there's this wide
disparity with old voters and young
voters so the reason people were
freaking out about Game of Thrones
possibly being affected is because it
films in Northern Ireland which is part
of the UK which would be affected by
brexit in one of the reasons Game of
Thrones films there's because it's
amazingly beautiful but they also
received tax credits that helped them
save money on the millions and millions
of dollars it cost to film Game of
Thrones so people were thinking that
Game of Thrones benefited from a lot of
European Union tax credits so if the UK
were to leave and they were to continue
to filming in the UK that means they
might not have access to that money
meaning that it could affect Game of
Thrones episodes in season seven and
eight like they might have to do less or
they may have to cancel it that is not
the case
most of Game of Thrones money comes from
UK specific tax credits which would not
be affected by brexit so like all that
you know the millions and millions of
dollars that cost the film Game of
Thrones of the credits that they receive
you can think of it as like bonus money
most of that bonus money that they
received based on the place that they
film would not be affected by brexit so
do not worry it's not going to shorten
Game of Thrones run there are people at
HBO whose job it is to make sure that
stuff like this does not affect the
actual filming of episodes you know like
really crazy political things going on
in the world in worst case scenario they
would just go find somewhere else to
film so there's no need to worry but you
could think of it as Daenerys burning
the cows by setting the tent on fire
she didn't light the cows on fire she
lit the tent on fire and the cows just
didn't make it out in time because the
fire burns so fast imagine a large
portion of the UK sets itself on fire
Game of Thrones would just moved
down the street away from the fire
rather than let itself be burned alive
so yes there will be some long ranging
catastrophic effects to the UK like life
in the UK in general they're saying it's
gonna trigger another Scottish
referendum if you don't know what the
Scottish referendum is before all this
brexit stuff happened Scotland tried to
vote to leave the UK if they're like
alright screw you guys we're going home
we want to be by ourselves
that didn't work cut to a couple years
later we have bricks it now the UK is
leaving
so all those Scottish people that tried
to leave earlier like hey we should try
to do this again if the UK can leave the
EU then Scotland can leave the UK so
right now it seems like the UK is
imploding while setting itself on fire
that's not exactly what's going on and
it's not like some crazy little finger
plot to devalue the British pound even
though the British Pound is going way
down it'd be like if little finger we're
trying to bring down the crown instead
of pushing it into debt by devaluing
gold so like Lannisters have lots of
gold imagine little finger wanted to
bring them down not by putting them into
debt but by making gold worthless so
while things seem really bad in the UK
right now and there's a lot of confusion
as to what's gonna happen long term the
effect on the worldwide economy and
trade isn't gonna be quite as bad as
people think it is one of the reasons
for the EU to exist is just to make
trade a little bit easier it's like all
the Seven Kingdoms coming together
imagine the Seven Kingdoms and Westeros
all breaking apart what they would do is
they would just charge extra taxes on
trade so things would get a little more
expensive and it would be a little
harder to move around as quickly as
little finger-like moving across
Westeros in a single day you would not
be able to do that anymore you'd have to
go through border checks each time you
pass into a new part of the realm so the
good news is is whatever the producers
and HBO's plan for Game of Thrones
season seven and eight was going to be
it's not going to be affected by brexit
so for example if there was going to be
13 episodes for the last two seasons
total that's not going to change the
actors will still get their
half-a-million dollars there's about
five actors on the show five main actors
they got their salaries bumped but
they're only doing about 13 episodes the
next two years like the episode count
has been reduced so yeah they're getting
more money but it's not quite as
exorbitant as it sounds like the actual
payout after the next two seasons isn't
as high as you think it would be there's
seven episodes like seven times
half a million dollars that they're not
getting because they're only doing 13
episodes total Peter Dinklage Kit
Harington Lena Headey Emilia Clarke and
Nikolaj coster-waldau so you basically
have the Lannister children Jon Snow and
Daenerys that are getting that salary
bump all the other actors are probably
getting a little more money but
dramatically below that half a million
dollars so I do think it's interesting
that even though Sansa is kind of a main
character she's getting like half of
what Jon Snow's being paid so take that
for what you will but don't worry brexit
is not going to set Game of Thrones on
fire Daenerys style Game of Thrones is
like brexit unburnt cannot be touched so
no worries so what's happening this
weekend is I'm at VidCon I'm actually
making this video from VidCon so I will
be walking about today I'll be posting
new videos there's some flash rebirth
and there'll be so new Game of Thrones
Sunday like things will be back to
normal by Sunday but I'll be making
videos from VidCon on Saturday too
it's gonna be a lot of fun I've already
seen a lot of really fun social media
posts about brexit so while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click over here on the site sorry I'm my
other hands holding the microphone you
can click on the side for more Game of
Thrones and then the other one for more
Game of Thrones too so I'll see you guys
this weekend if you do see me at VidCon
feel free to say hi
you